[Music]
time now for pft on yahoo sports chris
sims in for peter king mike florio
talking about some of the big stories in
the national football league and let's
go
big picture today christopher shall we
sure favorite storyline or favorite
story lines
of the 2020 season now that we are
closing in on the end
of the regular season what stands out to
you the most well okay i got a few here
let me just throw like throw out a few
right that just are in my mind here i
mean first off big ben
his comeback story the washington
football team
ron rivera alex smith i think that's a
great story
the chiefs can they 15 and 1 go to the
super bowl
josh allen's emergence but to me i think
it's two
and it comes back to two number 12s that
i think i go to
i mean brady in tampa bay is my favorite
storyline i think of the year
you know just hey again the amazing
level at which he's playing
some of the you know things we've had in
the media bruce aryan's taking his shot
doing that brady with holding up the
four as it's it's only third
you know some of the mistakes he's made
but how he's bounced back
how they look right now to me it's
between that
and the aaron rodgers revenge tour those
are my two favorite things this year
mike just
hey drafted a quarterback and aaron
rodgers said hey green bay
up yours i'm going to be the mvp of
football this year i like that too
and the fact that the buccaneers are
peaking at the right time yeah could be
on a collision course with a rematch
with the green bay packers in green bay
in the postseason the buccaneers won
38-10 after spotting the packers 10
points that could be
as great of an nfc playoff game
as bill's chiefs on the afc side and i'm
gonna go
just big picture here because if you had
told me in september
yeah where the pandemic was going to be
in late december i just said there's no
way they're getting the full season and
they're going to get maybe 10 games in
may if they're lucky
nine games was how many everyone played
in 1982
in the strike shortened season they
still had the full playoffs they had a
16 team
field that year but i would have dreamed
that or i would have never dreamed that
they'd get
the full season in and here we are in
the brink of week 17 and they have
somehow the one major sports league in
america that has managed during the
pandemic to get its
its full season in even though there was
a sense as the season approached that it
had squandered
its five-month head start that it hadn't
properly prepared
that it wasn't ready for what was coming
but they have managed to hold it
together
through outbreaks through guys all of a
sudden not available coaches aren't
available just we're going forward we're
going forward we're going forward and
they've gone forward
and it doesn't feel like the season has
been compromised in any way because of
it chris
no mike listen uh you know mine were all
football related but i think you know if
me and you went head to head there you
won that is the that's the storyline of
the year
there's no doubt about it i mean we
didn't think we were going to get this
season done
in totality we had all these question
marks you know
all the jobs that are dependent on it in
the nfl
our own jobs everything i mean what the
hell would we have done if we couldn't
talk about it
we were rooting against football we were
rooting tonight that's right this year
don't you remember that oh that's right
yes right right well you know the
internet's not the most reliable thing
in social media right now okay so we
know that too but
it is amazing and he got it hats off to
the nfl
for the way they've handled it you know
the very impressive
best when they first released the
protocol and things
it's the best we've seen i mean our
country didn't lay out a protocol
like that so uh way to go nfl
all right uh a way to go to you for
giving us some of your time today and
all year long for pft on yahoo sports
we'll see you again real soon see ya
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports